[Music]
hey listen i know you love it when
you're right study
i know you love it when you're right
so you are always i'm gonna just bash
just basketball you never you never said
i was wrong though oh no no this is this
is more american that would have been
better but america i've watched you get
beat up when we're doing live events uh
and on the internets
on social media about
you always tell everybody we always tell
everybody to get joints check uh
checking accounts and bank accounts and
don't hide money from me there was this
real instagram reel going around and it
was like you know basically say
something that no one would say out loud
and you like point and you put like a
thing and i put when you get married
combine your money including one
checking out and you would have thought
oh i yeah you would have thought that i
was like you're
you everyone out there i hate no you
would have thought you could put like
invite your neighbor over for yeah yeah
dude it was you got some a lot of heat
for it it was like hey go drive to a red
light and whoever's next to you in the
car combine you're checking everyone's
like you're so stupid like i thought
that was my advice all right so
gladstone garbinski
mogan learnt
mog and lindner sorry that i just
butchered your name
um in the journal of personality and
social psychology
this is the abstract um
ultimately
when couples decide to share their lives
their assignment simultaneously faced
with a decision of how or whether to
pool their finances so this group of
psychologists is doing a study to find
out
um does the way in which couples keep
their money affect happiness in their
relationship so they took the rachel
cruz ism
the ramsayism and said we're gonna put
it to the empirical test now they did
six different studies now i haven't read
the methodology here but so this is just
the abstract but
their sample size was almost forty
thousand people including primary and
secondary data which in your world
that's a lot right that's a lot
um so
again i haven't looked at the
methodology but here's what they came
across across six studies about forty
thousand people that couples who pool
all of their money compared to couples
who keep all or some of their money
separate experience greater relationship
satisfaction and are less likely to
break up
joining bank account
though it can it benefits all couples
the effect is particularly strong among
couples with scarce financial resources
so empirically
if you will put all of your money in the
account and deal with all of the anxiety
and all of the hard conversations and
all the push and pull that that that
will entail
the data says you're less likely to
break up and you are more likely to
experience greater relationships
and what else do we want in a marriage
to not break up and to experience
satisfaction in the marriage well we
talk about this a lot in money and
marriage but it's so in our event but
it's so funny to me and you're the one
that said it so i want to coin you but
i'm like
you will share a kitchen with someone
you will share a bed with someone you
share your your genetics
together the little person running
around you're sharing literally your
genetics are so human together but when
it comes to your checking account that's
my money no i earned it no where's my
300 for the light bill it's like what
are you talking about you know what i
mean yes
it blows my mind and i do know people
have a lot of
trigger points and fear around it
because of past experiences right like
there are there's legitimate
people walk through legitimate pain and
hardship
to get to that and to say i'm too scared
now to still go in
full force to my second marriage or
whatever maybe
but still okay so if you're choosing to
get married you guys if you're choosing
to share your life
and the reason you don't is another
reason is people say well we just fight
all the time we file time it's it's
easier just to avoid the conflict but
that's the exact thing that you have to
have yeah to have to have a better
marriage you're just avoiding it and
when you're avoiding that you're
probably avoiding other things right
like if if your thought is i can't ever
have that conversation it's just getting
in a fight or i can't ever talk to him
or her about this because it would
then don't get married
do not get married because that that gap
in communication that gap in
the ability to have hard conversations
and do hard things together will show up
somewhere and there's going to be kids
involved or there's going to be a
mortgage or a business involved there's
going to be in-laws involved it only it
only magnifies from there so if the
thought of sitting down with somebody
you're dating or engaged to and saying
hey it's a big deal to me that when we
get married we pull all of our money
together if you can't do that call it
call it because what's coming for you is
going to be worse and worse and worse
and worse okay so for people that are
married though and that this is still a
point they're like yeah you know i i had
a uh dm come through oh my gosh someone
slid into your dms into my dms and i i
don't always check it but i was just
home and i was like going through them
and she was like yeah i'm thinking about
getting a separate checking account for
just my spending
um because he kind of harps on what i
spend my money on and i'm kind of just
tired of it so we do everything else we
budget together that but just my
spending i want a separate account
and i messaged her back i was like hey
no
no because the issue is not having a
separate account the issue is that your
husband's either being kind of a jerk
and and poking at you and bringing up
things in the past to throw in your face
that you've spent
or
maybe what you're spending y'all aren't
agree on and he's frustrated like i
don't know who's right or wrong it
sounded like you know she was more right
but obviously she was the one that dm me
but i was like no you can't don't put a
band-aid of things on your relationship
and that's what people i feel like do
all the time we'll just figure out
systems in marriage
with our money so that we don't have to
like go there we have to engage we don't
have to we don't have to go there and
i'm like go there go there it's painful
and it's hard
but it's worth it like that that's a
deeper marriage and finding out as much
as you love somebody that they're not
going to be your forever person because
they can't honor your safety before you
get married
call it right and if you are with a
spouse who steadfastly refuses to join
then here's how much you've got to go
connect with somebody that's when you
call and say i'm gonna go start seeing
somebody i'd love for you to join me
because this marriage isn't safe because
you don't trust me we don't trust each
other enough here and you and i both
heard of of
people who blow all the money because
they've got addictions who blow all the
money because like well i just need a
new rifle it's like well yeah but we
need diapers it's like well you figure
that out yeah everybody knows of that
and so we're not talking about those
there's a small percentage
yes yes or there's yeah an addiction
with gambling or yeah something else yes
there's most people most of the time yes
put your money in the same account yes
yes right and here we won't keep harping
on this but but another thing too that i
would love to for you to speak on though
is that there's i hear for women
especially don't depend on a man like
like it is sell independence is
celebrated where it's like oh no i can
take care of myself i don't have to you
know and that idea
that can rot a marriage as well right
this idea that i'm going to continue to
stay separate from you to take care of
my own self that's still a level a guard
that's up that you're not allowing
terry reel who i consider america's
greatest therapist he's just
extraordinary he's a great author um
he says that the great lie that women
were told coming out of the 50s and 60s
and 70s is
you don't need anybody and you can do
this all by yourself and the great lie
that men were told is the rules didn't
change because the rules did change
and your wife got a seat at the table
when i was doing research for my book
yeah my mom who got married in
70
was not allowed by law to go get her own
checking account without my dad's
signature until 73
wow this is our parents right this is
the arc of our parents relationships i
blew my mind right so the rules changed
for men and women men have to have to do
things differently yes they have to be
more inclusive they have to sit at the
table they have to have hard
conversations they have to invite
partners into these conversations in
ways that they that their grandparents
didn't yeah
and the lie that you know what you can
do all of this by yourself is not true
we're not wired that we're not built
that way and that's not woo that's
co-regulated science that's who we are
we got to do life together yeah so you
guys i mean here are say plays i know
we're kind of like
you know harping on this topic but for
real it's hard man it
the money and marriage conversation it
is it's so tough because your marriage
issues come out in all different ways
and money is one of those avenues it
comes out through money and so there can
be tension there can be fights
but digging in and working on what's
really going on underneath the surface
and and seeing yourself as a team inside
and you both come to people that's right
like i you know sometimes it's all put
on the woman and it's like yeah cause
she's the one that's doing a lot of the
household spending and all that we see
that in studies and so
for some women they feel very isolated
because their husband's not helping he's
not engaging in the conversation or the
flip is my dad did it i'm doing it in
the flippers
yeah i'm just i'm gonna just you know
yield to him and he can just no you have
a voice too step in and you guys working
together you're going to be different
opposites attract so be prepared for
that we both feel bad
in our marriages but but man i'm telling
you
combine this your marriage has to be so
tightly unified and use money as a tool
to be one of those things that that
helps